[Music]
shortly after the massacre in Norway the
media started searching for
scapegoats certainly they said oh it had
to be the work of a Christian they
always do that but then they began to
put part of an of the blame on an
influential American blogger Dale herd
has that
story some news articles about the
killings have suggested that accused
mass murderer Andre braik was inspired
by a handful of bloggers who write about
the dangers of Islam on the internet
braik sought to kill members and
supporters of Norway's ruling labor
party which he believes has allowed
Norway to be
islamicized and the Press has zeroed in
on one respected Islamic expert in
particular Robert Spencer who blogs on
the website jihadwatch.org
tonight officials are pouring over this
1500 page Manifesto that braik wrote he
quoted heavily not only from America's
unibomber but American bloggers like
Robert Spencer who shares a suspicion of
Islam Spencer is the author of 10 books
including the New York Times bestsellers
the truth about Muhammad and the
politically incorrect guide to Islam he
also leads seminars on Islam and Jihad
for the US military the FBI and the
intelligence Community critics of Islam
have long been accused of hate speech
and some believe the Norway Mass
Massacre is now being used as an excuse
to further stifle criticism of
Islam we're joining us now as a prolific
author man has written I believe 10
books he's got a Blog out about Islam he
has uh studied for almost 30 years uh is
20 years or so Islamic thought and he's
here with us today Robert Spencer it's a
pleasure to welcome
you likewise thank you tell me what it
is about the media today that seems to
be in favor of radical Islam why why do
they want to put down anybody who tells
the truth about this or this
cult well I tell you I think the
unpleasant truth about it is is that the
media being hardle is essentially
anti-American and so anything that's
American that's Western that's Christian
that's judeo-christian they hate and so
they see Islam and it's non-western and
non-Christian and they love it well how
can they love murderers these people are
murderers they kill American soldiers
they kill innocent
civilians well you know to be sure it's
not that they're approving of that
directly because they are propagating
the uh propaganda line that Islam is a
religion of Peace that's been hijacked
by a tiny minority of extremists and
they constantly gloss over and sometimes
outright deny the fact that Islamic
jihadists use the texts and teachings of
Islam to promote violence and to incite
Peaceful Muslims to commit acts of
violence these things are matters of
fact it's pretty obvious from what
jihadists themselves say say you wrote a
book about Muhammad you have studied
carefully his writings and he wrote the
Quran and what does the Quran have to
say and what did he have to say about
Jihad well Pat the Quran says that
Muslims should wage war against Jews and
Christians this is chapter 9: 29 it says
that Muslims should wage war against
people of the book that is primarily
Jews and Christians until they pay the
gizia which is a special tax that
Muslims are exempt from paying with in
submission and feel themselves subdued
and that verse became the foundation for
a whole elaborate super structure in
Islamic law that uh it mandates a second
class status for Jews and Christians in
Islamic societies so that they're denied
basic rights and even though that's not
fully enforced around the world today in
Pakistan and in Egypt and elsewhere
there is a systematic institutionalized
form of discrimination against the
native Christians in the country so that
they can't get good jobs they can't
build new churches or old ones and
they're subject to all sorts of forms of
legalized harassment and discrimination
you know I read something the other day
one of these writers was saying well uh
if the the Muslims take over they
they'll give uh everybody Demi status
like that was a big deal did you talk
about
that well people you know it is funny
that people talk about that as if it's a
positive and a lot of times I've heard
Islamic apologists say it means that
Jews and Christians are exempt from
military service in the Islamic State
and isn't that great but it's not that
they're exempt for military service
because they're some sort of privileged
class they're exempt for military
service because they're not trusted and
they're not really full citizens and
they are uh made to pay this tax that
the non that the Muslims don't actually
pay as a matter of fact if you look back
at the great Islamic empires of the past
when they were the military powerhouses
it was the non-muslim communities within
those states that paid for that
expansion and that military but they
weren't able to serve it it themselves
and they uh were were made to pay this
tax as a sign of their humiliation and
disgrace because they had rejected
Muhammad and Allah well let's talk about
the so-called
copat the the ones today I mean the
majority of Muslims actually believe
that they will establish a cipate that
will extend from sea to
Sea well I don't know if it's a majority
in the United States that's really hard
to determine but I can tell you that the
Muslim Brotherhood has been dedicated as
a matter of fact the Muslim Brotherhood
which is an International Islamic
organization was founded in 1928 in
order to restore the caliphate which was
abolished by the secular Turkish
government in
1924 and they have their best shot at
doing that now than they've ever had
because they're about to come to power
in Egypt and they have Allied
organizations about to come to power in
Tunisia in Libya in Yemen possibly in
Syria and elsewhere and uh these are all
organizations that want to unite the
Islamic World under a caliphate and so I
think it's very likely that they're
going to
try I one of our guys we do a lot of
work uh in uh Arabic themed programs in
the Muslim world and uh the head of that
working for our organization says he
thinks that the foundations of Islam are
crumbling because people are hearing the
truth on the internet and through the
various media that are out there today
that they they've been brainwashed to
many years now now there's a a turning
away from the extreme form of Islam is
is this true or
not oh absolutely Pat it's 100% true uh
I have information that there are
several hundred thousand people in the
Islamic world who have secretly
converted to Christianity they have to
do it in secret because Islam forbids
conversion Muhammad said if anybody
changes his religion kill him and
there's actually a death penalty on
somebody who leaves Islam and becomes a
Christian or leaves Islam even and
becomes an atheist or or or anything
else and in the Islamic world that makes
for a very brittle culture that can't
stand any kind of criticism because it
uh it they they know that it won't stand
up to scrutiny and so they have to try
to uh they well in this case they try to
demonize anybody who speaks the truth
about the elements of Islam that
jihadists use to justify violence and
that's why they're trying to blame me
for Norway and also they uh have to
close off any kind of uh uh questioning
of their own Doctrine because they know
it won't stand up but people are seeing
through it it's hard in this internet
age to block the truth out and so a lot
of people are getting the word out and
as that number begins to grow I think
that ultimately they're not going to
have to live in hiding the way they do
now well last question how about you are
you threatened do you do you have death
threats against you or there fought was
issued against
you yes Pat I have many many and as a
matter of fact uh since this Norway
thing I've gotten four new death threats
and I expect they'll continue to come in
what do you do to protect yourself so
let trust the Lord well you know uh when
I go out and speak in public I do have a
guard but uh ultimately I think uh these
kinds of things are in the hand of God
and uh I think that when it comes down
to it it's not as if I'm not going to
die if I stop telling the truth so I
might as well tell the truth and just
let the chips fall where they may Robert
thank you very much and may the Lord
keep you safe thank you thank you you